[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com head over to the shop support
the fight and buy some cool
threads it's the tits pajamas.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's june which marks louder with
crowder's sixth annual
cultural appropriation month where we
take you across the globe
to learn and appreciate all the diverse
cultures this planet has to offer
because to appropriate is to appreciate
join us comrades for the final week as
we journey through the streets littered
with used
starlets and human [ __ ] allow us to
transport you to the communist
cesspool that is california
i don't know if that's a little bit of
the hiv oh cause california
happy cultural appropriation month to be
here i cannot see uh gerald uh
gerald a here is uh first off we don't
have anyone in third chair today i need
to tell you
dave had a funeral to go to that sucks
because someone had to be selfish
not his own and uh well that remains to
be seen
there could be it they could get a two
for one special but uh we'll be talking
about california today and joe biden
just uh made some
some new gun mistakes and by mistakes i
mean lies
of course and we'll also talk about why
california is definitively the worst
state in the union
um not including of course uh the state
of baltimore ah yeah but uh before we
get to that hey gerald a how are you sir
doing well stephen glad you brought me
mr dorsey
i i'm not aware of what you're talking
right yeah no you'll look into it
quarter black how are you sir oh you got
a dollar yeah well i just need enough
money to get a bus ticket oh yeah we
have some stats too in california
the funny thing is we don't have the
stats of uh of 2020 or 2021 where the
stats from oh that's convenient 18 to
2020. those are my stats
[Music]
those are not those are not yours there
are nobody's i apologize guys look
jordan peterson uh
had another appointment yeah we were
going to have him him back on sooner of
course this is my last show for a little
while
live because they're going to cut open
uh cut open bruce's chest hey
great job on the wardrobe and and uh and
uh the costumes by the way just so you
know this is oh i don't want to see that
is this just the shirt my thighs yeah
yeah i'm gonna criticize my biceps get
them
get it it's always fun when you're
wearing a liner
these swim trunks and underwear yeah no
that's too many
one wrong move and this seam is a high
tension cable wire oh wow yeah
testicular torsion so before we move on
here it's time for some
california facts
[Music]
whoa dude uh
a lot of people don't know this berkeley
was the first city in the country to
begin a widespread aids education
campaign ah
okay okay that's good uh a new
california state mandate states that all
gender revealed parties are b-y-o-e
bring your own extinguisher
yeah also um i'm getting where they just
banned all gender revealed parties
ah yes so that's also changed and a
statue of o.j simpson still stands this
is true
in brentwood today we're not tearing
down the statue of o.j simpson
uh kind of disrespectful of course if
you ask me but
he was a he was a great he was a
fantastic murderer
so it does make sense they're just
signing what's uh what's that
what am i hearing what is that some
music is that oh oh
no oh what what is what is happening
it's uh oh my god i don't feel
comfortable
all right that's enough for you nice to
see that's very good okay
all right all right hands up okay yeah
yeah wonderful let's get let's go okay
no okay you know what
yes sid you know what no listen dad stop
don't play the music again no oh my god
get him out of here
bryce leave get out just just we hate
all of you bryce get out of it get the
heck get the hell out this is so
you did uh this is pop's crowder
craw daddy um we did caitlyn jenner and
honestly i
i feel a lot of shame just not you
shouldn't feel shameless that dave was
supposed to do this
and then looking at my father like this
that's
heart that's hard i don't know what
you're talking about stephen how are you
all right okay we don't have to daniel
day lewis this thing to hold
someone want to
i appreciate it you're not even going to
your shoulder is going to get so you can
hold that mask up the whole time who
goes from the low maintenance
life of a dude to this yeah i know every
day
delusion yeah somebody with time on
their hands this just honestly threw me
i didn't expect that
and i don't like it i'm not enjoying it
but this is bruce jenner who won the
awards and then caitlyn jenner woman of
the year
ah so very account maybe he'll have a
statue in brentwood
of course that it'll be honoring his hit
and run
it was a good job got away with it um by
hiding out
all right speaking of which we have some
questions of the day by the way would
you ever make your dad do this you can
i just i'm sorry thank you you can by
the way you can comment below
did you just take bugles and wrap them
and wrap them in tin foil
are those palladium coated bugles what
i think they're lovely steven i uh oh no
they're you're not following
me by the way notice the most disturbing
thing a straw so he doesn't screw up his
lipstick
it's probably one of those i requested
it fellas yeah i've questioned that
it's probably one of those paper straws
that just sticks together i think
caitlyn needs a few more requests denied
whatever happened to that in the united
states no yeah she didn't hear that word
enough no she did not hear that word hey
should i dress up as a woman and you
know do some weird
no no no no no one around the scenes
let's not do that yeah
but it'd be a real great way to get my
record expunged but i killed somebody
and this is my way to hide you know what
this has gone off the rails so let me
just say this
you generations in millennials my
generation you don't appreciate
what bruce jenner actually did yeah the
incredible magnitude
of that feat uh pop star you were
talking about this it's not just that he
won
the you know this decathlon before you
know four black guys figured out the
sport
it was it was it was it's absolutely
true
you look you see these people sprinting
and it's like a bunch of white guys
you're like oh well
that was just a matter of time but it
was the russians were doping and they
were professional and this guy
bruce jenner for all this crap that's
gone on now yeah
was paying his way through college
competing against professional
dopers and beat them right well before
the turn of the century stop
stop please uh that's exactly right he
was working his way through school doing
it as an amateur athlete against the
best on the planet that were just
human experiments oh yeah come on the
whole eastern block just
human experiments yeah let's uh let's
move caitlyn's a
mic a little closer yeah because it's
giving me a little bit of echo all right
before we move on to anything else
perfect uh let's react to this while
we're talking about california here's a
guy
on the tick tock by the way i've been
banned from time yeah what removed
just this morning here's the new one you
know yeah oh is there a new instagram
instagram and then tick-tock i don't
really give a [ __ ]
i don't well you should i don't i'm at
that point look irritating throttle on
facebook demonetized on youtube
throttled on youtube and then like oh a
tick tock i wouldn't even say that
that's a cherry on top because no one
cares
no but i mean the the debauchery that's
allowed on tick tock and
it's like you got to stay there to piss
them off i know but the good thing is i
don't have to listen to any more
nurses i mean heroes heroes that's true
they're daily tasks oh i'm sorry you
have a job
so oh no
it's called it's called being an adult
nurses and teachers unions and sometimes
that means
you're going to have to do things that
you don't want to do
like go to work
interesting concept yeah so here's a guy
on tick-tock
uh saying this is the new rule now that
straight men
can just okay this is i swear
this is this is this is and i and yours
truly removed here you go
do you know that straight men can have
sex with men and not be gay
they can huh my first few videos were
about straight men having gay sex
and i'm getting activity again and
comments that people don't understand
that straight men can be attracted to
the sex act
but not to the man straight men having
sex with men doesn't cancel
somebody's heterosexuality any more than
a straight woman
having sex with a woman cancels her
sexuality
and it's not about by erasure either
please don't say that
bisexual men are attracted to both men
and women to different degrees
straight men are not attracted to men
they're attracted to the sex with men
oh could some of these men be gay or
bisexual
absolutely but that comes over time and
that's a trajectory
that only they can be in touch with to
figure that out
not the therapist and not anyone else so
before you leave comments
please watch my earlier videos
so hold on a second they're not
attracted to men they're attracted to
sex with men
and straight men can have sex with
he's gay right is that yeah yeah i think
so i think i figured it out
yeah exactly oh well well you know tick
tock it's it's still not the gayest
thing i've seen in the gym
i'm just
wow he could have used the smaller 25
plates but he wanted the big rum
yeah that was that was token and by the
way um you are
less gay today than what you did in that
gym i mean wow
that's unbelievable i love this they're
not gay they're not attracted to the gay
men they're attracted to the sex
with men it's like oh i didn't look i
wasn't doing it i wasn't doing it for
the
the for the rape it was i just enjoyed
the sex part of it
oh so you can separate a rapist right
yeah those sounds like the greek thing
well like it's only if you're the person
receiving that you're gay
you're giving you're totally like so
there's no emotional connection
it's prison rules
watch steven crowder and mr raping look
joe lewis doesn't even like being in
california he's not not at all
surprised he's going looks comfy though
in uh in other news calif uh
not california sorry kamala harris come
on harrison go to the border now did you
guys see this yeah
he's finally going to the border
politico reported uh tomorrow
so it took six months of being in office
three months of being officially
put in charge right of the border crisis
and uh i don't i don't know um this just
seems of course politically motivated
when people
know it's funny to me when the left says
stop politicizing issues you're
politicizing science
you didn't want to go to the border just
because it was bad and you knew that
it would look bad for you if you
continued to do anything because
donald trump did right well she's like a
petulant child i don't want to go
because you've told me that i need to go
yeah well he's going to be visiting uh
is what the home homeland uh
his next wednesday yeah yeah he's
visiting oh there you go you have it in
the over yeah so that might have
something to do with it and greg abbott
he's in a wheelchair
he is he's going to be there too he
found a way
rolled his ass down there geez don't
forget a guy in a wheelchair uh helps
stare down the nazis
this is he did yeah yeah well truman
dropped the bomb yeah
or as i call it world's greatest gift
so no by the way i absolutely think we
should have dropped the ball yeah yeah
drop it twice
and uh and uh we did go ahead change my
mind that's something
like do you have any idea the amount of
i thought everyone here was like oh
that's a little intense no we had the
weapon we should have used it because we
saved a bunch of lives in a land war
sorry tokunawan but you didn't like the
japanese either
right oh no the okinawans did not like
them yeah they destroyed our temples
like twice
yeah ah because you rebuilt them you
jerks you didn't get the message the
first time and one time i i had a
japanese man destroy my shirley temple
it was a horrible dog
the atrocities i said a dir a dirty
shirley and make it a double a bird
flies on two wings
donut hiroshi
so uh lidar's credit actually has
obtained compelling exclusive footage
from the border which also may serve as
the reason come on harris is going there
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i hope he finds him i hope he finds
what he's looking for
mainly maracas just miraculously by the
way that terminators use a bird fly on
two wings don't it that came from an old
uh
neighbor of my uh my wife at the time
who was my girlfriend uh and i just
think i think we should revoke all old
people's driver's licenses
well that's true because they're always
drunk ages they're always drunk i went
over to his place he invited me over for
his like happy hour which is you know
like a bunch of
white fish pate and shrimp that's been
sitting out for a long time
i don't know what age crossover where
temperature doesn't affect the taste of
meat to you right
it was also 10 a.m yeah no it was 11 a.m
this is not a joke
and he goes uh what do you want to drink
and i don't really drink a lot of
cocktails and hard liquor at this point
i didn't drink really at all
and uh i said i don't know what he goes
i'm gonna make you a dirty shirley
i said okay uh that sounds uh that
sounds
it's entirely inappropriate for 11am and
uh he goes you want me to make it a
double and i said i don't
i don't know a bird fly on two wings
don't it and he poured like six ounces
six ounces of gibby's gin okay gotta go
yeah and then he drove oh then he drove
to brunch
i don't think that's so it's not so much
being old as being
completely hammered yeah but it's just
they do it they do who's gonna stop
them old people really do have like a
just get as drunk as you possibly can
because who cares what power to kill
as much as they want uh and like i said
guys we are going to have some
some videos long form content some
change my mind's coming up yeah and a
mini documentary about the surgery that
have coming up because
it's supposed to i'm supposed to not
work for like several months
but that's not going to happen i'll just
be gone for a couple of weeks
um it's uh it's it's pretty invasive and
i don't really want to go through it now
so if you want to know about what's
going on the mayo clinic great work
that'll be up
next week or the week after and uh you
know hopefully uh hopefully uh
i don't die can we do is this like a
discovery channel documentary where we
actually see them crack your chest open
i think they might allow us to actually
go into
the surgery really yeah yeah are we
gonna have to blur that
hopefully not i have no idea huh it
doesn't matter i don't give a rat's ass
i don't need to play by tick-tock rules
anymore
i didn't think they had rules i swear
you make your own rules uh we'll go to
the gen z thing afterwards but uh
let me ask you this john mcafee before
we move on this is a story and i didn't
want to report
on it because we don't have a lot of
info it's either something nefarious or
the world's greatest troll
yes uh but the media hasn't really
talked about john mcafee dying for
people who don't know i'll just give you
a really brief recap okay
he created the antivirus software that
you no doubt have on your computer and
cannot uninstall
it is a virus uh and he committed you
know tax evasion they said he went down
to belize was accused of maybe murder
then he went to guatemala back to the
states anyways
he was arrested uh based on tax evasion
put in a spanish prison about a year ago
and then finally was cleared for for
being extradited to the united states
died suicide in his prison cell right
yesterday here's the thing he said many
many times that he would not commit
suicide yeah he even had it tattooed he
had the word wax tattooed
yeah exactly if i die in custody
that's right he didn't have he was a
daniel stern fan he couldn't put in
bushwhack
so it's just a text it doesn't really
serve its purpose but he said
i will not kill myself okay look for me
so either he was doing this the whole
time
or legend there could be something going
on this is a guy who has a lot of info
on anyone because his his
entire software's in computers yeah and
he was obsessed with privacy the guy was
i don't know how much about him is true
if you watch that documentary
i have the person who made it made a
very pro-clinton documentary so it's
really hard the reason i'm not talking
about it
is because it's really hard to sort of
piece together what's true and what's
not
and i need a little more time with it
but i do want to ask you this
doesn't it at what point do we say
there's a pattern
like that's honestly all
i was trying to think about are there
any like can you think of any bernie
bros
who got offed in this kind of way no i
was trying to think through that i was
like
seth rich ish but it's sort of negated
by the clintons the dnc
stuff but i'm saying it just always
seems like people who are libertarians
who are anti-government types or people
who have dirt on powerful people
they always just seem you know how many
how many failures
can happen are they all driving priuses
[Laughter]
or the jeeps that you that back up and
suicide in the cell i just yeah
you know while on suicide watch with
cameras and guards except
you know he was digging into epstein
obviously he had it so i i don't know
you guys and you know what this is sort
of crowdsourcing if there's something
i've missed
let me know i don't i don't know the guy
seems nutty
kind of a funny aside though the whole
nutty thing i know somebody who works
at uh mcafee and this person said to me
well
you know we're really sad obviously but
he hasn't been a part of the company for
like
20 or 25 years and now we can finally
stop having to answer the question about
him
yes every time he does something stupid
we were like hey um but what about like
this we're so they have to go to all
their customers and say remember he's
not associated with us anymore we just
have his name
yeah he made belize look real good
though yeah as a as a place to retire
oh boy he highlighted that part of the
world if your neighbor gets mad about
your dogs barking you just off them
that's no no you can't call it a day go
use some bath salts
so again i don't know none of this none
of this seems to add up but who knows uh
here's something that we do know okay
i talked about joe biden uh and the
white house.gov we provided the sources
we always do live with creditor.com
uh his proposal for effectively the gun
registration the gun
ban yeah but he just spoke yesterday
again on uh his intent to sort of curb
gun violence specifically in these major
cities of course this tan amounts to
more gun control to more federalized
authority
but you knew that so i don't want to go
to the registration to buy back because
we have already done that you can just
search that alarmcutter.com don't try
and search it on youtube because you
will find nothing
surprised um but he just made a claim
yesterday that the left has been making
for a very long time okay
and it's verifiably incorrect about uh
this is the common blame game right well
if you look in these big cities they're
actually getting guns from elsewhere
it's not the big city's fault but he
made a very specific claim
because he said the quiet part out loud
they probably said don't say
and he just remembered don't say that
that people are pointing out
gun crime is a problem in major liberal
cities because that's a deadlock
so don't say that and then he said that
here you go
we discussed disrupting illegal gun
trafficking
now the gun lobby wants you to believe
that cities that are the toughest gun
had the toughest gun laws
still have the highest rates of gun
violence correct as was pointed out by
the group we had today in our round
table
the the violence is so they argue why do
you need those
gun laws if they don't work in cities
that have tough laws
don't believe it here's the truth
today's conversation with mayor scott in
baltimore for example echoed
what we know to be the case in here for
mayors all across the country
mayors have the power to help shape and
enforce the laws in their cities
but they can't control the laws in
neighboring cities and states
even though the gun legally bought there
is often ends up in their streets
mayor scott says that 80 percent of the
guns in baltimore were acquired outside
the city
outside of fact mayor he can do about
that by the way
i love what it says a lot of people say
you know and they use these uh
verifiable uh
stats and and statistics but the mayor
told me no
i went with it but it's not our fault
piece of [ __ ] i'm sorry i'm so tired of
the sky
i'm so tired of someone like there is no
if that was don
that were donald trump we're going to
get to california yeah we don't need it
we don't need to dump that that's okay i
believe the former vice president is a
piece of [ __ ] okay
this is a lie he just takes stats right
facts and then says
the mayor said no if it were donald
trump they would say where are you
getting that sir were you doing that
yeah
they would never source they did the
same thing we'll get to it a little bit
in california with wildfires
and not clearing the brush oh of course
he was right we now know it's right how
because we have receipts for 500 million
dollars let's say he was right
but this is a claim that joe biden and
by the way i haven't slept in two days
oh man
and i can tell a man who is completely
lost he's lost the plot
well he doesn't have anybody around him
that says hey you need to look into this
claim before you repeat it
no i mean he doesn't have anyone around
him saying you need to crawl into a hole
and take a snap animals go off to die
alone
what are we doing but this is just a
recycled claim that you heard from
barack obama he tried to make this claim
because everyone pointed to his hometown
of chicago
and this is well it's actually not it's
actually not chicago's fault it's
indiana it's well here you go they go to
a gun show
uh in indiana where right now they don't
have to do a background check
them
and open up that band and sell them uh
to kids
uh and gangs uh in in chicago he thinks
that people are buying firearms at a gun
show the way he bought crack with bill
ayers
for people who don't know i know just so
you know
barack hussein obama did crack
with bill ayers con convicted domestic
terrorist oh wow he wrote about it
it's not a secret it's not a conspiracy
yeah that's in the book so he's saying
chicagoans go to these
horrible crime riddled areas where there
are plenty of guns
yes and bring the guns back that's
exactly there's no crime in these places
where the gun no there are no crime and
there's very little crime in the places
uh
places that he's referring to as a
matter of fact i went to the specific
location
which i can't do anymore now because i
get recognized there's no undercover
can't move
don't have jim henson on the payroll but
um he
was specifically addressing a place
crown point indiana where they have a
big gun show yeah i went to it
specifically to see
just so you know if i could purchase
without a background check
i give this to you no this all gets sent
to the atf
i can't do i mean to get that home today
there's no way to do that
i was told that i could go to a gun show
and there would be no background check
so there would need to be a background
check that's a problem
[Laughter]
i was told by the president that i could
go
here believe him that's a felony in 20
years and
i'm not going to mess with it
no no you tried you know what the truth
is i actually really wanted to get that
magazine-fed shotgun oh really yeah and
i couldn't so really the victim in all
this is me
yeah how does he get away with saying
something like that like you can just go
over the border an indian and buy guns
without a background check and nobody
goes
you can go and here's what happens
people say
hey and this happened after hey you want
to get a gun without a background check
and it's a criminal
who then tries to sell it to you in an
alleyway like that can't happen
in the bastion of safety that is chicago
that's the whole point right he's saying
that there's this gun hole
gun show loophole that we've talked
about before no it's people committing a
crime who don't follow the laws that you
write now so what do you think why do
you think they're gonna follow ones you
write later there's no gun show loophole
there's no evidence that the problem in
places like chicago
baltimore that this is coming from uh
you know states like texas and oklahoma
or neighboring states indiana there's
just no evidence
who's detroit gonna claim canada you
know what detroit and toledo they kind
of volley back and forth and they just
blame each other but look i'm a
michigander
that one's on us toledo and
one exit away it's like detroit
flint and then toledo and you're like
ohio make the list you're like well come
on let's look at the proximity there's
no discernible difference there's no
discernible difference
okay so here's the question is it true
of course it's not true but let me give
you some general stats and also
something
that a lot of people don't touch on
because a lot of these stats just like
when we talk about homicide or sorry
firearm deaths
we're not talking homicide deaths often
when you're talking about that total
number right they're including suicides
and when you take that out per capita
gun homicides in this country
very very low and when you understand
that a huge portion of that is gang on
gang violence
and again you see a higher trend of that
in cities
for example like in dallas a lot of
crime not a lot of
crime against civilians and i'll get to
that in a second yeah now it doesn't
make it right
no of course not but a part of me thinks
you know let the crips and the bloods
clear each other out but you need you
need to understand where the stat comes
from too right you have to understand
that most of that is made up of gang
violence and those are the current rules
that aren't following the laws that we
just talked about
so general stats chicago saw an increase
in shootings of over 52 percent in 2020.
minneapolis saw 105 percent increase in
shootings in 2020
dc 2020 increased uh sorry from 64
from 2017 because that was the last time
they took those stats baltimore
shootings were up 17 percent in 2020.
and it's kind of low for baltimore i'm
like did they stop counting these
they're like no no no no no like hey cut
it yeah he tripped and fell but he had a
bullet wound
so let's blame the fall morbidity kind
of like exactly yeah kind of like
epstein and mcafee in a cell yes
pretty much no that's six to the back of
the head
this rifle has an ext it has an
extension and a scope on it right he had
some string we saw i guess i don't know
i must have steven spielberg alien arms
[Laughter]
so um this doesn't tell the full story
because this is something too that i've
always
it's very hard to find some numbers yeah
uh out there uh
crime against civilians carjackings
actually are a great
indicator and you can read up on this
there are a lot of people who've talked
about this sort of people who who study
crime and have to make inferences
there really isn't a lot of data hard
data on uh for example a lot of
ballistics data that we have
is not very accurate so it's hard to
know how many shots are taken to stop
an intruder because sometimes the only
data that's collected these are
municipally
and uh it just collects the deaths you
know just the death numbers not
necessarily the numbers of people who
were shot or who were fatally wounded
and died later
same thing with carjackings they're
typically reported on a municipality by
municipality basis i don't believe
there's a federal database but
it is important here's why carjackings
and by the way uh
pops crowder you know about carjacking
detroit invented the car jacket sure did
they really
oh yeah that's why you leave a space
between the you and the car in front of
you
so when they rear-end you you have an
exit strategy because they're trying to
use oh yeah they actually coach you how
to get out you stop at no lights
in certain areas um no you roll them you
treat them as stop signs or yields
and you leave a gap between you and the
car in front of you i remember that was
this like the dmv
training were they like yes no
everything's gone it's on the test
that's how my
that's how pops crowder trained me when
i was driving so he's like just so you
don't get pinned i'm like
dad we're in montreal and i'm pretty
sure no one wants to steal
my 94 cavalier right so i know you're
english you're in trouble yeah they they
taught us how to parallel park for you
they're like
for screw that you're not gonna need
that you're gonna need to know how to
get it carjacked carry this gun
you pull up to the wrong area in detroit
and you stop at the stop light before it
goes green
it's just a frame on cinder blocks
they are efficient nothing happens yeah
so uh this is important because the
carjackings are a perfect example look
no one is carjacking another gang member
carjackings are a good indicator of how
emboldened criminals are
to simply uh commit a crime against an
unarmed civilian if it's in an area
presumably where guns are controlled
because think about it most carjackings
where they occur they don't occur on
country roads they often occur
in populated areas where there should be
a police presence
against a civilian and so there are
several assumptions that have to be made
for criminal
to commit carjacking successfully the
person is unarmed
the police are ineffective and no one
will do anything and it has to be in a
crowded area
okay chicago carjackings increased 135
percent
dang in a year could say that
significant
that sounds high until minneapolis and
st paul the twin cities
carjackings more than tripled ah hold my
beer chicago
washington d.c quadrupled in 2021
compared to 2020.
quadrupled carjackings in washington dc
we have the sources all available at
lightworkcrowder.com 135 percent
increase seems pretty bad
yeah it does until you see quadrupled
right
now are you seeing tripling and
quadrupling in areas where people have
open and concealed carry no not those
numbers there may be some there may be
some exceptions
but the only real city that i know of
that's a large city that's still run by
a republican mayor is i believe oklahoma
city
yeah i believe that's the last one and
you'd have to be an idiot to carjack
somebody there
the guy won't even roll down his window
and you'll just be spouting water out
your stomach like gremlins too
there's a fire right through the door
all these cities have like just this
common
thread i mean i wonder if we could do
some kind of statistical analysis and
yeah
conclusions from that so if baltimore's
if baltimore's crime is not from
baltimore
or chicago where's it from this is the
question
where is it from and where is the data
look you can look at the data
and it's pretty self-evident that okay
chicago baltimore detroit we see a trend
and we'll get to california in a second
not only violent crime but homelessness
yeah and in in breaking and entering it
seems pretty obvious and so for me if
you were going to say hey
the obvious answer here where there's a
consistent pattern
is not the actual answer well then it is
your duty to provide some thing that's
compelling yeah
evidence would be helpful here does
anyone out there again i know we have
some left just to watch the show not
leftists but classical liberals yeah
anyone have any evidence that it's
coming from somewhere else so baltimore
sun how far is dc from baltimore are
they kind of
it's not very far it's about 45 minutes
i think an hour yeah yeah okay so that's
yeah
far enough yeah it's they're both awful
no not far enough
well they're not they're not both far
enough away from the united states well
yes that's that's a very true point yeah
uh the baltimore sun article actually
this is what they claim that the top two
states maryland uh
uh they they import guns from sorry are
virginia and pennsylvania
okay okay and this surprised me so let's
compare the states that's a weird
maryland 4.5
violent crimes per 1 000 residents okay
now pennsylvania
which i thought because you still have
pittsburgh and philadelphia yeah
3.1 violent crimes 1 000. that's slower
you take away philadelphia it's like
half that
geez virginia 2.1 violent crimes per 1
000
it's not even close well it's the it's
the white supremacists that are coming
into town they're the ones
they're driving in from west virginia
yeah that's what they do in all men
marry a black man to be found in philly
no
not at all well the justice department
told me white supremacists were the
greatest threat to yeah they were the
greatest threat yeah i guess you're
talking about a quadrupling in
carjackings
you really think there are a bunch of
american history x ed norton look-alikes
carjacking people
in baltimore probably not keeping a low
profile
oscar worthy that was a good performance
and this guy goes out there and this is
the question too people say well why is
he why is he
look you know the answer to this why
would he just go out and say that and
feel comfortable
saying that's not what the stats say
what do you think the answer is
no one's going to call it no one's going
to call him well look at the next
logical step right so maryland can say
oh it's these other states and he says
okay well the federal government has to
step in all right so let's make an
entire policy
for the united states that will take
care of this problem okay well we have
neighbors
we have canada and mexico we can't
control their gun policy and guns
obviously come across the border so what
are you gonna do then not many from
canada run this thing through to the end
joe
yeah if guns are coming from these
places and in your utopia you get that
solved how do you take care of mexico
because i think there's cartels down
there i think they have guns i'm not
sure i've seen sicario
looks like they do they put heads on
turtles i know that in canada you're not
really getting much it's
it's you're just getting a few wrist
rockets they're dealers they're armed
dealers just dennis the menace
if you show up and you see a kid in a
striped shirt and overalls run the other
way
sad news hey where can i get some little
bastard ammo little poppers you throw on
the ground
mr wilson's head is just crawling by in
a box towards us
they just hope you get caught in the
maple syrup okay dennis all right
now here's something else too when
you're talking about the swamp uh we
talked about it
continuing on guns david chipman
uh is the one who um he's the eighth
been appointed you know atf director
yeah well yeah hasn't been confirmed
hasn't been controlled that's right
that's like charged versus convicted
that's true or in david shipman's case
like charged versus convicted
so he's the one who wants to for people
who don't remember and i have some
interesting information here
on where his money has gone uh let's
just
i'll i'll get back to the masjid in a
second this is the guy who wanted to ban
assault weapons and couldn't even define
the term
uh when being questioned officially here
yep oh it will come back i want to turn
to a second matter now mr shipman
you have called for an assault weapons
ban i have a simple question for you
what is an assault weapon
senator um an assault weapon would be in
in the context of the question you asked
what congress uh defines it as
well so i've been in walmart's and i've
been in cabela's and i've seen that you
can find
sections for for pistols or handguns or
for shotguns
or for rifles because those are actual
kinds of firearms
i think our exchange here illustrates
that there really is no such thing as an
assault weapon um you know how people
have often said sunlight is the best
disinfectant yeah
if you actually just put a uv light on
david chipman he turns to ash he does
shrivel up and die
yeah yeah exactly by the way if you're
going my inner powder
if you're a guy who is trying to
determine policy or
enforce policy for the us government
yeah you never go in and say
my job is defined by whatever you say is
wrong with the country i will go and
take every gun out of every home if
congress says that they are all assault
weapons how in the world is that
the right kind of thinking if you watch
the full interview he later
defines assault weapons he talks about
it just flows right out of his way he
says
refer back to the definition and talking
about the attorney yeah he casually uses
the term assault weapon
he says ar-15s and other assault type
weapons he says that
right but other assault type weapons is
even worse because that includes every
basic hand
what if congress comes out and says
handguns are assault weapons by what he
just said it's like well
whatever congress defines it as i guess
i gotta go get those i didn't have time
to define it i was too busy eating flies
very specific and disgusting
i'm a child they tend to hang around the
human feces on the streets
yeah so um and by the way we're gonna do
our costume contest winner on mug
later on play a california theme hipster
hobo so uh just wanted to let you know
to send your stuff gonna be tough
so actually shout out to uh i don't know
this person but mom at arms who drew
attention
to this for us i don't know how many
people have talked about this fec the
individual contributions uh
their data which is uh available shows
that david chipman biden's the atf
director again this guy
um it shows how much he donated to
prominent democrat organizations
now let's get go through these numbers
again thanks to mom and arms in 2020
okay just 120
to act blue pack that doesn't seem like
no 500 to biden for president
that's not a whole lot uh but then he
did give uh to be fair
just want to be fair two thousand
dollars to a republican organization
really yeah the lincoln project
dude come on so his here's the thing his
um
hatred for republicans is just
outweighed by his
love for pedophiles yeah the lincoln
that's what it shows um
can they really be classified as a
republican organization come on
that that's been done i mean at a
certain point like when people are mad
that you're besmirching the reputation
of someone
uh you know lincoln you know not a
perfect man
taught himself to read by candlelight
you know was a wrestler was a great man
with an axe uh emancipation proclamation
freed the slaves slaves and you guys are
groomers hmm lots of comparisons there
yeah i just don't think you should be
comparing grooming pedophiles of the
lincoln project
abraham lincoln no yeah doesn't pass the
penny test
so there's also records of david shipman
donating to barack obama in 2008.
his wife tara has given twenty-two
thousand dollars
the democratic organizations including
one thousand the biden's campaign
so the total from david and his wife
david shipman to democratic
organizations
uh since 2008 is something around 41
000.
jeez according to fec does that include
the lincoln project
i have no one we should that should just
be lumped it does include it
okay of course i was just facetious yeah
of course it includes a link
anyone surprised did you guys know this
i had no idea that and look i mean
people can give political donations as
much as they want but when somebody
comes in front of their their hearing to
be confirmed and they say
i don't have any strong opinions on
doing this job whatever you guys tell me
to do you're like uh
you know we're gonna have to talk to
somebody else about this by the way who
do you think you're gonna side with on
this
do you think you're gonna push back if
joe biden does something illegal or if
congress puts out a plan that's actually
illegal are you gonna push back no
you donated to them you're in bed with
them already right we need somebody who
has a little bit of balls in that well i
think there's a little bit more than
that look
it's not only just giving to democrats
but here's the issue when people say i'm
not anti-gun
right they say i'm just i'm pro-gun
control i just want responsible gun
ownership
what balanced legislations have the
democrats promoted in other words
all the people david shipman is given to
right
where have they said hey let's let's
make it more
accessible for law-abiding citizens to
protect themselves let's make it harder
for criminals to get them hey we're not
we're not anti-guns so
here's a balanced proposal in other
words as opposed to saying hey we're not
anti-gun but we need background checks
we already have them we need waiting
periods people die when they have
wedding periods and they have
restraining orders
and we don't think anyone's able to own
basic handguns we'll define them as an
assault weapon
well that's silly where is the balance
that's being proposed the balance is
just fire double double barrel shotgun
in the air
and this guy wants to be legal in
control of the atf
there wasn't he also the guy in waco yes
well their problems aren't going away in
these democrat cities because because
they're
they're escalating well their policies
can't fix them they can't be fixed yeah
so they're not going away they'll always
have to deal with that issue
right and when you're talking about guns
will you stop blaming an inanimate
object for problems that you're having
in your city will you blame
criminals please will you focus on the
actual problem oh wait hold on a second
cnn is live right now
homicides in minneapolis on pace to
reach highest totals in years
let's see how they spin this okay we're
here live the
harm that has happened at the hands of a
dysfunctional police force
oh yeah yes this has to be transformed
that's our demand
um that's where the whole slogan around
uh black lives matters comes from
and while we do that and while we invest
in social supports
in and ending the racism and education
and health and income and wealth
and all of that stuff we have to also
higher than average for people spending
in minneapolis
sufficient levels of staffing of police
officers
that will keep our babies our elderly
wait hold on a second
when you say defund the police and we
need sufficient staffing
doesn't that require funding or do you
just expect everyone to work in
perpetuity and collect unemployment
checks because that's what you want to
do that's what
biden wanted to continue i don't
understand how do you staff the police
force
everything she just said was double
speak and stupid i feel like jim carrey
needs to break in and just be like stop
breaking the law
[ __ ] yes maybe that would help
that's where you need to start
and then we'll talk about these other
programs no no no no it's racism and
schooling and uh you know
what not let's hear her talk more what i
would say is that some of the decisions
have just been premature
and they've harmed the very people they
were intended to help and then
funding the police yeah you said our
babies so let's talk about the kids of
minneapolis for a moment
at least 22 children by the way a lot of
youth are involved in
carjackings now too so again like i said
minneapolis st paul
triple we just we brought that up
earlier tripled the carjackings
yeah now they just say a lot of kids
shot a lot of kids by who performing
carjacking
by who so in other words for every
carjacking that is recorded successfully
how many are thwarted by someone
defending themselves their god-given
right so let's
let's see if they even touch on that
ladavian garrett jr
shot in the head in april riding with
his parents
as a black mother what what
reform right you say don't defund
but reform police what saves our kids
right so what saves our kids and i think
the president said this great um in a
wonderful way poppy
all of us to really think through
what our solutions are but your city
council hey guys bring it bring it up
there from the uh
the research room it was was it the city
council or committee that voted to
defund the police there was like nine
votes there was an a there was an actual
city council or charter yeah
so let's get them in education the
racism and housing the racism and health
the racism in in the disparities around
income
i mean it's all of that it's all racism
you have to get it right so you believe
that you've seen a tripling in
carjackings
against civilians because of racism and
housing and health
that makes sense and education don't try
and education don't
don't forget that even though there's
higher per pupil spending no teachers
unions of course we need more money
uh will not allow charter schools uh or
school voucher programs at all oh no
those are better for kids and we don't
want that did i say that out loud oops
and again it was your stupid city that
voted to defund the police
this is just again none of them are
called mini minneapolis city council
votes to remove eight million dollars
from police ah that'll get more cops on
this that happened right away she think
maybe we rushed to decisions
well now i'm hearing you rushing to
other decisions
i can't believe this i really can't i
can point a second ago but like
not one word about saying
men step up in your communities and do a
better job of being fathers
not one word about family saying hey
step up and make sure that your kids out
on
are not out on the street committing
crimes and joining gangs and shooting up
cars
the people that they just put up there
to kind of pull at your heartstrings the
kids were shot by people who just
randomly shot in cars yeah it wasn't
i don't know maybe they might claim they
were cops i have no idea they were not
cops okay there's been no claim that
they were cops it was thug
criminals that did that and you're gonna
be like well how do we fix it
as a black mother yeah as a black mother
hey how about just a as a mother who
wants a city without crime
how about that let's let's those white
supremacist thugs gerald they had to be
there yeah it was
a black bomber jacket into town yeah
focused on which i'm excited by
look sandra you have said that this is
really at the heart
of the fight for the heart of america so
we will continue to have your voice
on this on of course you will no you
know what you're fighting against the
heart of america let me be really clear
you are fighting against the heart of
america
when you believe that the kinds of
policies that you voted for in
minneapolis
uh are what americans want 80 80 plus
percent of black americans keep in mind
this is something too that no one wants
to talk about that broad
on that television okay is only walking
back the defund the police to
reform because she is completely
out of touch with black america right
the voices that we see on cnn the voices
that we see on abc nbc cbs if you were
an
alien bp and you landed right here on
earth you would think
that all black americans must want to
defund the police
until someone says here's poll after
poll after poll
at intervals of three months it's never
lower than 80 percent
it's higher than white people the last
poll was white people 77
said at least as much of a police
presence or more over 80 percent of
black people
yeah where's their voice you know what
they're doing they're calling out for
help in their communities and you're
saying we need to send in social workers
and we need to defund the police
how in the world can you be that out of
touch with what people need and this is
also by the way the
the beauty of being able to do this show
live you know there's
nothing up the sleeve this is happening
live right now we didn't intend to talk
about minneapolis crime and them
go up there and spewing their [ __ ]
this is what happens
all the time and let me get a little
conspiratorial with you here
oh okay um i absolutely no i don't mean
conspiratorial because uh
what inspired this uh this this idea was
the black lives matter website in their
charter so
oh yeah okay they say they want to just
seek the destruction of the nuclear
family yeah that's what they say because
it's an example of white supremacy in
patriarchy and the two are often
they've already done that yeah well
that's obviously what they're trying to
do right
right here look the the the most
the most significant safeguard okay
against
not only an overly encroaching
government but all of society's ills
nuclear family mommy daddy kids period
it's not even close
we all know this this was the
foundational building block of this
country
that the only way a constitutional
republic like this that afforded more
freedoms than any country
before it and still became a global
superpower by the way as opposed to
a nation of drugged out libertines was
we need
before federal government before state
government we need the nuclear family
and that's why it was encouraged
and when you hear everything she just
said it's about
public schooling it's about racism in
housing
it's about racism in health care that is
now saying
it's the government's job to do all of
those things for you
not mommy and daddy it's not their job
to take care of you trust big daddy
government yeah
we're like the big brother program we're
the one who's going to help you it is
it is easy to get your claws in in
children
just like lincoln project if you're a
sexual predator if you're a grooming
pedophile guess what you'll look for
someone with a weak family structure
yeah ideally someone without a father
figure
it's really easy for big government
socialist policies
to get their clause in you when you're
at your youngest most vulnerable
and you don't have someone to watch your
back like a dad
yeah and somebody to honestly if you do
all of these policies if you enact
everything that they want to get rid of
the quote unquote systemic racism that's
plaguing their communities
you're not going to fix the problem no
they're not still going to happen
in broken families and you know what
else too people often use this term deep
state and most
a lot of people who use it are morons
where they just want to say deep state
deep state deep state
here's what here's what to me when we
talk about that because it's a valid
point what it actually is
unelected officials who enact basically
laws through regulations
people think that it's just a law you
have people
like chipman yeah is he going to be
elected
but he's going to have a say on whether
you get to keep that
that revolver if it has a 10 round
cylinder he's going to have a say
if your glock 19 is still allowed in
your state
he's going to have a say if you have a
rapist tracking you down in new jersey
right you have a restraining order and
he's blown through it but you have to
wait 30 days
he's unelected guess what people who are
unelected are going to have a say
on what your police department is
allowed to do people who are unelected
are going to have a say in how much you
spend on local housing
these are unelected people who serve
exclusively to protect
other unelected people if you actually
look at washington dc and you look at
the amount of people who work there
yeah who work in government who were
actually elected as part of the
constitutional republic
versus people who work there and throw
up red tape bureaucratic regulations and
i'm not even talking about lobbyists i'm
not even including them
that's what the deep state is anyone who
is unelected and a career politician you
know
people like fauci people like chipman
yeah people who have been in there
forever and have no accountability for
their past mistakes
i'm not saying that there's an
underground pizza parlor where the
lincoln project keeps kids chained up
against the wall
what i am saying is someone like a
fouchy
someone like a david chipman david
chipman who was involved with
tear-gassing women and children in waco
fauci who was wrong about everything
when it came to aids
and cost potentially millions of lives
has more control over your life than
your family if they had their way
that should scare the [ __ ] out of you
and that's not conspiratorial
that's reality that's the deep state
right and the left is actually pushing
those individuals as
being correct and above reproach yeah
right they're deifying these people and
saying oh well they just are
fantastic we've gotten the experts in
the room now don't question
don't look at what they've actually said
and don't look at what the results have
actually been from that
it it really is it really is remarkable
so and you guys can you know
you can let me am i wrong what do you
think of deepsea i think it goes beyond
just
career politician like joe biden because
at some point he was elected at least
the politicians are out front right you
can see them you understand what they're
doing it's these other actors behind the
scenes that are just in government
appointed positions that you never hear
about at least they're out front unless
you're a nine-year-old would you abide
in any
well that's you know it's hard to sniff
from in front
cornrows aren't going to sniff
themselves so uh
let's continue with this you know a
perfect state that's an example perfect
city detroit
oh you know what before this can we do
we have that girl we have that girl uh
right now um do we
know is we have parents you know what
let's include the parent i think at this
point
i think it's important to include this
this is actually in talking about this
uh parent of the week here we go
and this guy was complaining i believe
at a parent-teacher conference and
you're seeing this more because um
parents are finally aware
of what their kids are being taught yeah
they're going wait a second
wait actually andrew breitbart who um
you know i was sort of sat under his
tutelage
i remember he brought out uh and i think
we brought this up a long time if you
have kids
i'd probably have them get rid of the
room right now uh get them out of the
room right now yeah
not get rid of the room how do you do
that i can't do that i don't know ask
joe biden you throw the room away i
assume they can
take in the padding or take it out um
yes kevin jennings i believe
was it kevin jennings uh there's one guy
who's jeopardy i believe it was some he
was head of some
department of education some some type
of education czar you guys can find it
and there was audio tape of him teaching
uh
junior high schoolers how to fist each
other what yeah
that's a good thing no no it's not
futurism yeah pugilist boxing yeah oh
he was teaching them how to fist each
other and this was something that of
course
people thought well it's just
conspiratorial andrew breitbart just
like i said with anthony weiner remember
that they were saying oh anthony weiner
andrew
that's ridiculous alec baldwin said this
anthony weiner story has a whiff of
breitbart well
you mean it's true true yeah so um this
kind of stuff you know and then you had
parents now going to
teacher conferences going you're
teaching them fisting wait you're
teaching them critical race theory
you had my child fill out a form as to
what sins they're guilty of because
someone in their lineage may have owned
slaves
people are waking up it's not just about
critical race theory
parents have taken too inactive of a
role particularly when it relates to
public education yes i think right now
if you send your kids to public school
personally i think you're doing your
child a great disservice in the united
states of america right now
do whatever you got to do to send them
to anything other than public school and
if you have to sit in the
public school you better be involved
with
every thing because you are handing your
child off
for eight hours a day to now we know
not necessarily heroes blue-haired angry
feminists who refuse to give your kid
a cupcake because he's a straight white
male yeah this is what's going on
it's less education and more
indoctrination yeah in a lot of these
schools
also not every teacher of course i would
say maybe 30 education
70 indoctrination and uh 200
aggravation ah yes that was my johnny
cochran i like it yeah
yeah good job education indoctrination
it's not affirmation you know what's
really interesting too it's not just
that parents have realized what their
kids are being taught it's they realize
that the school boards
are accountable to them they realize the
power that they now have over school
boards and they're showing up at these
meetings and they're starting to push
they're realizing it but you know who
doesn't the school board exactly yeah
they don't understand
they again it's just they call the cops
just like the the left has been so
unaccountable for so long from the media
teachers they thought well no one will
question we're the heroes
we've got a union we have our own we
have our own teacher signal yeah yeah
it's just just closed for pedagogical
day because uh you know alfred
that's this you know what what are we
going to do work work
11 months a year are you out of your
mind sir
nine sounds like a good number i thought
it was amazing the guy that was taken
down at the loudoun county
uh virginia yeah pta meeting perfect
takedown by the cops in that instance
yeah with the parent yeah perfect take
down uh this is so much with the guys in
the streets no not so much summer
no not so much uh no it depends on it's
it's it's context driven
of course he was yelling so here is a
father yelling i don't know where this
do we know where this took place someone
can let me know
um at the local school board about what
they're teaching the children not only
that but this
i believe the school board tried to stop
parents from even being allowed to
criticize here
this is my comment not your comment i'm
quoting to you now from the united
states supreme court
1964 case new york times versus sullivan
this is constitutional case law in this
country and i'm quoting you
from the u s supreme court the just the
judges wrote
that this nation is founded on the quote
profound national commitment to the
principle
that debate on public issues shall be
uninhibited
robust and wide open and that it may
well include
vehement caustic and sometimes
unpleasantly sharp attacks on government
and public officials that's
constitutional case law in this nation
i don't have to be nice to you nobody
behind me has to be nice to you
if you don't like living in the united
states of america then you can all move
to russia
cuba or china this is the first
amendment
put that guy in our team i don't care
about his fruity accents right
new solicitor there is a video camera to
my left
if you edit this tape then you're going
to have a big legal problem
which is what this is is
constitutionally protected
there are emails public record emails in
which the director of equity
is lobbying and advocating for public
comment to be
censored in this school district and you
know what
you know what lobbying for it advocating
for it we've got the scoreboard present
saying she'll do better at hitting the
moot button
in blatant violation of the constitution
for her lobbying and her advocacy
of unconstitutional censorship i want
you the school board
to terminate the employment of dr
charissa gibson with immediate effect
you're here oh he ain't done
he goes on i know he goes on we just
can't run the phone no i know you know
what he said after that he goes by the
way as soon as you've done that and as
soon as she's gone
every one of you must resign immediately
and by the way you know what's important
about this people always say when you
talk about oh you know censor
censorship on on youtube or on twitter
oh censorship is only government first
of all that's not really true
technically you can just you can censor
somebody anywhere it doesn't bring an
action of government
corporate censorship is a thing the
issue there is of course the cozy
relationship between big tech and
government illegally
afforded however it still is corporate
censorship but they go well why don't
you go start your own big tech okay
does it apply when you're talking about
a public education system and they're
trying to prevent criticism
against because guess what that's still
supported in other words there is no
case
where they would be well okay you know
what you're right no they try and say
there you go conservatives decrying
censorship again
what would you call it when members of
school boards and teachers
try to remove the ability for parents of
the children attending said schools
the ability to criticize what would you
call it is that no longer censorship
what would you call it when you're going
to spy on
americans right now if they're
considered right-wing extremists
deeming them domestic terrorists through
arbitrary rules that likely can be
decided by
members of the deep state meaning
unelected officials who
share similar views to david renfield
chipman
in other words at what point left what
point do you say at censorship
yeah when donald trump calls something
fake news honestly when do you say
facebook twitter youtube even though
they enjoy the legal protections of
being a public platform a utility right
not uh not being a publisher it's not
censorship
school board meeting it's not censorship
you don't have the right to be rude
no as a matter of fact the first
amendment is specifically
the right to be rude so my question to
people on the left including classical
liberals who don't want to actually
acknowledge that they're conservatives
now
what would you consider censorship does
it have to be the government beating
down your door
and putting a ball gag on your mouth
which by the way could be confused for
your weekly appointment with a
lincoln project committee member or do
you know june in san francisco june in
comes true or just any [ __ ] in
the years july
august yeah well you know i love by the
way that this guy goes and there's like
and i can't believe that we had to have
the supreme court tell you that free
speech didn't have to be nice
like that's essentially what it took
from it and he was saying
yeah exactly you're muting me because
you don't like what i'm saying
how in the world do you think that
that's okay and a british guy comes over
and quotes free speech by the way they
don't have that really in england no
they don't
really not at all right not at all i was
trying to be generous to them because i
have some english friends robust means
something
yeah not just exactly like kind of sort
of something very disturbing about you
saying the word robust
curling your heel well my size 15 pumps
stephen
they've got to make all new shoe sizes
for women now oh
pensbury school district in pennsylvania
by the way oh yeah hey
nice and we do have the kid if you want
to oh yeah yeah oh you know what okay
and i'll say this too that's parent of
the week we have kid of the week and
then we're gonna get to why california
is awful
um i don't usually like using clips
people kind of know this i have a
moratorium on using
children because i feel like people use
them as political yeah i'm sorry i still
keep laughing the jack dorsey
great job by the way francine that's
unbelievable that really
i didn't know if jack dorsey was going
to translate on camera it's it's it
couldn't be more clear as to who you are
i'm not sure that's a compliment i
usually don't like using kids because
you end up with like a greta thunderberg
who's not really a kid she's 18. she was
keep in mind credit thing brooke was
16 and a half right so they just dressed
her like she should be at build-a-bear
which i thought she was like 13 years
old
yeah whereas this next girl who looks
the exact age as greta thunberg
is nine years old and you can hear by
the way that she's speaking
that this is clearly the frustrations
being vented
by a nine-year-old it's one of the few
instances to me
here that comes across as authentic and
uh i will vote her president
i looked up onto the wall and saw a blm
poster and an amanda gorman poster
in case you don't know who that chick is
she's some girl who did a poem at
biden's so-called inauguration
i was so mad i went up to my principal
to tell him about the blm poster and
that
i wanted it down he said it's not coming
down i was like yeah it is because the
school birth
may 25th no blm or politics
in school he said that's weird they were
the one who they were the ones who made
them
i said there should be no blm in schools
period
does not matter the color you make the
posters and the fonts you use
we all understand the meaning it is a
political
message about getting rid of police
officers rioting
burning buildings down while king
governor walsh just sits on his throne
we all know changing the font or the
color of posters does not change the
meaning
i am nine years old and i know that
i love how she's so good she looks
exactly like greta thunberg
yeah um only you know unlike greta who
had to kind of you know use her window
of opportunity of a year where was
youtube's policy where you couldn't
criticize her
she's got uh she's got like she has nine
left
she's got nine left she's throwing down
the guys please sweetheart just use it
criticize
everybody they can't say anything back
they're not allowed it's big tech policy
get removed i love how often she's like
they said they said
i'm gonna take it down i was like uh
yeah you are i was like
yes contrast that with greta soon burger
you sit
on your throne of visions of endless
prophets and capitalism
when really we should ascertain shut up
shut up shut up you know what i guess it
was sort of self-fulfilling because no
one cares anymore
wow we continue to dare by the way i
love how she quoted the policy to him
she didn't just say
i don't like it she said uh yeah you are
because oh here you go
this is what you wrote yeah way to do it
yeah and he's like oh well that's that's
strange i mean they're the ones that put
the poster up and i was like ah it's
almost like there was some kind of
nefarious plot
oh and her inner american flag tank top
that she got at old navy before they
went purple for fourth of july
um all right so now let's move on here
by the way hit the notification bell do
if you're subscribed because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
especially
uh the schedule is going to be a little
bit intermittent here for the month of
july yeah
so i'm changing my minds some long form
videos every documentary
every july we take some you know we take
about two weeks off
uh so we don't want to hear in the
comments section where are you yeah well
no it's okay
we're coming back the next month there
will be about i think five or
seven like long form we have some match
wednesdays actually
one with uh jason whitlock one with
apollo and dave landau so
uh we've been pre-taping a lot of stuff
we have to upgrade the studio and i have
to open my chest
titanium rods but no not my heart's my
heart doesn't work well but my heart
itself is perfect i'll explain it later
it's my bone is caving into my heart ah
yeah so what happens if i punch you
really hard in the chest i die
ah really how dare you that's a missed
opportunity no i'm kidding
too many i like superman you gotta it's
almost the reason for getting it fixed
yeah
so uh let's talk about california since
it's cultural appropriation months
uh it sucks now we all know that it
sucks we all know
that california is not doing well right
they've had population loss which is
almost unheard of in a state with that
that much oceanfront property and
mountains
everywhere and just rich and natural
resources unfortunately
rich in natural [ __ ] so they they
tend to flock
it's just it grows it's something in the
soil capistrano field of the brim
so let's start with this a few reasons
why california is up hey do you remember
i think it was about this time last year
when donald trump
uh pointed out that california their
wildfires were out of control
due to poor forest management i don't
know if you remember it let's go back in
time
and i see again the forest fires are
starting
starting again in california i said you
got to clean your floors you got to
clean your
forests they have many many years of
leaves and broken trees
and they're like like so flammable
it's so flammable it goes up i've been
telling them this now for three years
but they don't want to listen the
environment
the environment i love how they play
that as a like yeah
yeah it's like it's actually true you
clean your floor and here's what they
try to do they
try to go donald trump i'm surprised and
say donald trump tried to uh
you know mr clean the floor tried to
pine saw you know the redwoods just like
they said donald trump tried to inject
you with bleach no he said
disinfectant said maybe we could get in
the body he said clean the floor the
differences
he says things that sound uh in our that
are inarticulate let's be honest
but he knows what he means exactly and
he's not whereas
joe biden has no idea yeah it seems like
that would be an industry term clean the
floor of the fort the forest floor they
probably used it mr miyagi did it
yeah clean the floor this is not i mean
so and i know we have some stuff we
gotta get to about this but this is not
rocket science like i follow this very
closely because of the wine business and
you're gonna find i'll give you a fact
after you go through okay well because
keep in mind that trump was mocked
mercilessly by the media right here we
have from politico uh usa today
they said that they didn't think he
understated the science of wildfires it
says
trump's suggestions have prompted head
scratching from experts who say his
prescriptions more raking less water
released into the ocean for
environmental purposes
suggest he does not understand the
science
of wildfires then usa today uh
reported the issue would only get worse
if trump
ignores climate change and gavin newsom
tweeted you don't believe in climate
change
you are excused from this conversation
hey that's a tactic of the left just
remove them from the conversation
just like parents at pta meetings or
people on big tech platforms
or the president from big tech platforms
or in this case the president from being
correct
absolutely well look you have wildfires
they're going to happen in this part of
the country every single year this is
not a surprise
what you see though is from 2012 i
believe to 2016 or maybe even
started just before that that this huge
drought right
not a lot of wildfires they had some for
sure but not crazy you know when the
first year that they had like crazy
wildfires in that entire stretch was
2017. you know what happened at the end
of 2016
it rained stuff grew then it died
then it caught on fire you know what
happened in 2020 it rained in 18 and 19.
stuff grew
it died it caught on fire if you get rid
of that stuff you greatly
enhance your chances of avoiding massive
out of control
fires by the way the last two i believe
were either caused by the gender reveal
or
the major ones were caused by pg e right
they've just been sued for that they had
to pay a ton of money for that they had
to go through and retrofit their lines
so they couldn't touch it
that's a good idea well by the way i you
get you get a couple birds in your beard
and you're
mr arborist i will listen i want good
wine to come from california in 2020 is
a complete you told me you had a couple
of tidbits sorry
because you know about wine that's the
whole segment that was a deep dive
you know no well and also by the way you
were talking about the peony uh
pg e sorry yeah um you were talking
about them then of course it's
exacerbated by them not
clearing the debris yeah by them not
doing controlled right
that's what people don't know and listen
by the way don't buy a house in the
middle of nowhere with the fire
department 45 minutes away
in woods all around you that's a bad
idea well how am i gonna how am i gonna
piss on a giant tree next to uh david
gergen dressed in a female tracksuit
well no i'm fine
we just won't count your body as the
toll you know like when you die we'll
just be like
no he didn't die there's someone going
nuts in the comments section right now
if they know by the way hit that like
button if you're watching right now
live this second you can do it hit the
like button
if you know what i'm talking about with
david jurgen at the redwoods
nine so guess what donald trump is out
of office
yeah yeah and kind of like donald
trump's out of office now we can say
maybe like before we're saying no leak
no leak there's no lab leak and then
he's maybe
did he close the door it might be only
donald trump is out of office
what he doesn't know anything about the
science why don't you talk about clean
the floor no clean the floor what is he
he doesn't understand climate center
okay yeah is he out uh all right uh 500
million dollars to start cleaning the
forest
this comes from bloomberg without all
this fuel on the forest floor
california officials contend blazes will
be less
likely to turn into the mega fires that
devour thousands of acres
well that's interesting it's almost like
that's a good idea
and by the way this isn't conjecture all
source is available at
lighterspreader.com
scientists said well we actually thought
the lab leak might have been possible
but we didn't want to be attributed with
donald trump kind of like people said
well you don't need a mask after the
vaccine but we don't want people to
think that we're freedom-loving
republicans
right well there was actually an expert
in an ap article from alberta
who said in one paragraph he said i have
donald trump's plan i'm paraphrasing
donald trump's plan
cleaning whatever that's not and then
the next paragraph down yeah absolutely
it actually helps if you do that to make
sure there's not enough fuel for fire of
course it does what i was like
are you the same person that said that
just the paragraph above
yeah that's why i need to be governor
fellows yeah you can make the change
you seem necessary
dangerously close to my home in malibu
as you know this needs to change
[Laughter]
you ain't black the only thing
dangerously close to malibu is you
this so yeah 500 million dollars uh and
we'll go back to
while you're talking about california
and their water issues
yeah that's another thing gotta save the
salmon and smelt smelt
assault weapons is another issue in
california it's not just wildfires that
suck and of course their their double
speak politics a few weeks back we
covered how a judge
of course said that the uh assault
weapons ban in california can bring up
the overlay
was uh unconstitutional that was amazing
right government is not free to impose
its own new policy choices on american
citizens where constitutional rights
are concerned we said well we don't know
if it's going to stand well right now
it's uh
not the ninth sword of course ninth
circuit blocked
benitez's ruling furthering rev and this
is important to note this is also why
when people say
hey the court look any institution can
be politicized
do you have a judge and then you had
other judges say no and then maybe
you never know sometimes it goes to the
supreme court and they decide another it
happens all the time
that's why we need a system of checks
and balances
right of course that's also why you
should have some people who are
somewhat accountable yeah well and it
shouldn't be like that but it is the
ninth circuit
circuit sorry is notorious for being
super liberal right
anything that goes through the dc
circuits as well same thing's going to
happen
same thing for these guys they do all
california the west coast arizona all of
it
so it's always going to happen like that
just wait till it gets to the supreme
court yeah we'll see
and by the way this this ruling is
especially bad in california
um really because of you know for what's
most bad for i don't know if it's
considered deterministic but rooftop
koreans people know about rooftop queens
it's actually a thing in california it
is but it's not what everyone thought
it's
they have a problem with what's uh they
have a problem with
rooftop what's is this in california yes
california
breaking yeah
well i just i just hope the girl from
stranger things it's safe i know well
look that just usually pisses him off
yeah
yeah you just that's not going to be
enough koreans get pissed off easily no
no i mean godzilla
oh yeah well
what are these bullets oh i'm just going
to attack the thing firing at me
and he holds the trigger before aiming
yeah that's true and it's not an
automatic it's crazy how it does
hey i have a quick breaking news update
oh what's happening
so donnie has been suspended from
practicing a lot in new york
oh really new york huh no an unbiased
state if i've ever seen one
hey look i understand i understand that
the law uh
needs to be respected and giuliani uh
maybe there were some
infractions um um but i suggest a career
in carjacking
that's going numbers are up yeah yeah
it's a growth future
just saying can i buy stock targeting
homelessness is another problem in
california of course we all know this
uh joe lewis actually crawled into that
tent we didn't know if he was going to
stay in the tent now he likes it he's
content
he likes it content can you imagine if
you just woke up and he crawled
into your tent could you imagine if you
woke up and that monster was in your
tent i would do whatever it said
like you know what he'd say the way he
said he mean business
you mean what do you say so homelessness
rose this is what's so shocking to me
you know that people are leaving
california people at daily wire joe
rogan bill maher is talking about
leaving california
can you leave your policies in
california by the way this little public
service announcement for californians
moving elsewhere
yeah it's great here because your
policies aren't here right
yeah because you haven't been here well
just give it time
uh so homelessness though before the
pandemic
2018 to 2020 rose 24 percent geez
yeah 24 wow and of course san francisco
is one of the main
i guess you would say main drivers of
this main culprits main shitholes
over 8 000 homeless people out of a
population of under 900
clubs grown that's a lot that's a huge
number of homeless people
piles of human crap it's almost
literally the streets
had laws that encouraged people yes
you would almost think so what's funny
is the mayor of austin when he was on
joe rogan's show he was talking about
you know we really wanted to get a
handle on the homeless problem so i
spoke with the mayors of san francisco
in seattle yeah
come again stupid did you really well
i'm kind of [ __ ]
this is because and then people say why
are you being tribal when you have a
mayor of a major city
in austin who really could speak with
any other mayor of a major city
in texas that's not austin and he's
reaching to the worst san francisco and
second worst seattle let's just be
honest about this when people try and
say they only try and accuse you of
being tribalistic
when you're a conservative and you just
draw a line in the sand and say no
this is what democrats do we know it the
only there are no people who reach
across the aisle anymore and i don't
know where you find common ground
when it's the party that believes
abortion up until
and including birth and they will
actively oppose
donald trump on forest fires on
lab leaks on economic policies just
because it's from donald trump
how do you find common ground right it's
like people who have a human
trafficking problem reaching out to
bangkok to figure out how they've solved
it and like oh yeah well let's call
cambodia too number one and number two
in the world
way to vilify an entire nation of people
there i'm sorry they're number one and
number two in the world in a
terrible crime yeah i can absolutely
believe it no seen it firsthand
um this is another thing of course
rolling blackouts in california now
we're talking about it california and
again keep in mind this is a state
that has so much water and it also has a
lot of running water
it should it's like there's also a lot
of people don't know there's a lot of
fresh water in california too not as
much as like michigan or wisconsin
but it also has oceanfront property
you're talking about a place that has
weather that is conducive maintaining a
population
really it's you'd have you would have to
attempt
to screw it up which then which they
succeeded it doesn't take that much
effort for them do you ever just drive
across this country and you like just
drive through
the phoenix area and you go huh wow
someone
really someone initially really put some
juice into setting up camp here
a lot of energy free air conditioning
pre
you know i mean nothing grows huh let's
just stop here
like that breeds a different kind of
person whereas you just walk into
california and you have to duck from
falling fruit it's just it's an
abundance of
everything the whole coast is just yeah
if you were to go back 100 years and
tell people
like yeah actually one of the fastest
growing areas are in
you know places like texas and arizona
like the place that doesn't grow
and you said you won't believe it but
100 years from now california
is going to be covered in human [ __ ]
what and you're going to run out of
water
okay obviously you're the crazy homeless
person because it's california
anything grows how do we run out of it
yeah you just you spit a seed
seriously and it it blossoms it blooms
what are you talking about i'm like well
you know what uh wait till you learn
about gavin newsom
uh jerry brown before him schwarzenegger
really you elected tonight he was too
busy banging the maid who well that's
true by the way that just shows you
terrible it's a love child terrible
because she's the most unattractive
human being
ever it's terrible on so many fronts boy
he must have been
bored i do it because and i'm locked
down yeah
it's no it's a crime it's a crime of
power
it was either her not attraction it's
power
take it then you're going to bear me a
son who will look like me i'll say
looks nothing like me they'll buy it
it's a spitting image she just really is
and she's just like i used to be a
republican
people this is the thing people who
watch the show all week you know what
that is but uh
follow the bread crumb like yeah yeah
exactly
well you know they dump trillions of
water or trillions of gallons of water
into the ocean every year
in california trillion trill yens
every single year because they say that
the pumping system that they use is
harmful for that smelt that you
mentioned earlier because they're poor
swimmers
and they don't lit like the next
paragraph sorry no
fish or swimmer so i did my research and
i knew about the smelt
are you telling me are you telling me
that that
tom selleck has to steal has to smuggle
water for his avocado farm
not to mention the people who are dying
of you know thirst and crops
because they have to save i know the
smell but they have to save the smelt
fish but this fish needs particular
protection yes
because it's not good at swimming
[Music]
now that you say nature selected them
for extinction
exactly that's like the island of misfit
toys a boat that can't stay afloat
you're not a boat anymore no
exactly and by the way you know what the
lifespan of this fish is
one year yeah well i think it should be
a significant i think it should be less
than that
absolutely what they do i think it
should be no years they blame these
pumps right that are going to give water
to i don't know
actual human beings that need it to
survive and they say
in the next paragraph oh and by the way
it has tons of new predators that are
eating it left and right but there's
debate on whether the
the predators are the problem or the
pumps yeah no the science probably isn't
in yet
if oceanic predators might prey on fish
that can't swim
it just makes it awesome get out of here
trillions of gallons crying out loud not
exaggerating that's like when that lady
in san francisco who was swimming with
the great whites got bitten in half and
they're like
do we have a cause of death take a stab
at it
take a stab at him david caruso
oh my god that microbe has a really
weird bite mark
[Music]
okay so i want to get back to the smell
because i didn't know that part wow
that's important
but the rolling blackouts and i know
you're going to say texas but it's the
totality
of this and yes texas may have rolling
blackouts but you also have to
understand that
we should be able to have an energy that
can handle us it's because of
bureaucrats who don't allow us to
utilize it properly just like california
but at least we don't have to save the
smelt
well you remember the freeway that had
to be rerouted because of the
plant that was believed to be extinct
they had to avoid they re-routed the
freeway this is in california
california yeah bent the entire
interstate because of a plant that was
believed to be extinct that had to be
flourished but they could just build
that transplant right over san francisco
like just drop it like roller coaster
tycoon good idea on to
san francisco so warning
rolling black out something they have uh
two-thirds of california's electricity
comes from carbon free sources well
that's very nice yeah except it means
they have to have rolling blackouts
gavin newsom
oh god here's people to shut off large
appliances and lights at 3 p.m
every day when this happens oh during
this major heatwave we need to conserve
energy a few simple things you can do
set your ac to 78 degrees or higher
during 3 to 10 pm
turn off unnecessary lights use major
appliances during
cooler times of the day so i guess
cooking dinner is out yes sorry by the
way you know what 3 to 10 pm is
the hottest part of the day typically
until about eight o'clock
thanks a lot gavin you also can't like
take showers like do laundry
well that explains something you can do
it's pretty bad it's much nicer to be
homeless yeah
the rules don't apply to you then you
can you're like me when i was a kid and
i get punished and get sent to my room
i'm like well i wanted to go to my room
anyway
oh don't wait
don't make me get free food anywhere
the soup gets soup it's gumbo day at the
soup cake
i'm lactose intolerant hey by the way if
i'm in charge of california
we're serving homeless people milk and
smelt
because they dump milk they dump milk
too to fix prices people don't know
about this this happens with milk and
cherries in michigan
oh so cherries in michigan they're very
persnickety crop and some years you have
an over abundance right and they don't
even allow the farmers to keep their own
cherries
like make pies destroy them so you got
to destroy them because we have to make
sure that the prices are fixed
aren't there homeless people to feed i
know right yeah that would be an easy
solution to the problem
yeah all right so california of course
this goes to droughts uh the most recent
one lasting five years in california
right 2015-2016 and why can't they pump
more water
environmental laws of course so uh
this goes back to 2008 the fish and
wildlife service plant
they place limits on water that could be
pumped out of sacramento
san joaquin delta and uh sent south to
central valley farmers uh to protect
yeah delta smelt yeah delta smelt so you
kind of
stole my thunder on that one but this
just happened so you would say they've
learned from their mistakes
yeah you would think yeah right they can
redeem themselves that's fair you're
falling asleep there
second chances put him in a dress it's
like a
he gets lulled to sleep like a womb look
just because you look like a woman
doesn't mean you get to
yeah no it doesn't mean pay attention it
is ma'am
i just know it's very i'm a horribly
ugly woman yeah well you are
you are like gene hackman in the bird
cage
that's putting it generously yeah last
week though we know about the smelt
before
right but now this is last week four
hydroelectric
dams in california in oregon uh
they they have to save migratory salmon
oh
yeah another fish we need to save the
salmon they have to be demolished
oh okay save the salmon what about power
to save people's
lives well they got to get their
omega-3s
you heard of krill oil oh by the way we
can't do that either
remember that was i think krill oil
krill used to be something they put in
dog food i'm just going off here because
you should i don't really carello used
to be used in dog food they would mash
it up was good and they would say that's
the most sustainable food in the planet
because it's at the bottom of the food
chain
right they always say don't go after the
apex spreader they said krill they're
like ah krill's at the bottom of the
food chain you can't take krill
that's what everything else is basically
they can't take salmon you can't take
krill
just eat the cicadas once every 20 years
if you survive that long this is
absolutely this is
this is a california is a master class
and how to screw up a state
just like detroit as a master class and
how to screw up a city people don't know
this detroit wealthiest city in the
world
in the 1950s yeah yeah i mean
unbelievable when i go to
california i when i look at the natural
beauty and the resources that they have
and
and honestly the p once you get out of
the major cities the people are very
conservative i had a i had a person i'm
not going to name them
winery owner in my shop yesterday and
gavin newsom came up and before i
i'm always careful because i i don't
really know oh he came up and he came up
in conversation conversation and uh she
goes ah that
boob oh jeez we hate him
they're conservative i appreciate you
didn't give the name uh
the the the name out so you know because
the moon davies wouldn't appreciate
you talking no i'm surprised you know
mondavi the sterling's
yeah what are you doing like reading the
box
uh uh mr menage a trois okay that's not
a person it was
madam naomi uh no i don't know these are
wines that i see i think i brought a
shot at this
thing gerald barefoot
[Laughter]
oh i hate that uh well thank you dad um
he's gonna tony clifton this thing
[Laughter]
uh we did want to include one positive
thing about california though because i
know there are good people like you said
left in california
so actually our uh correspondent thomas
finnegan went down there to give us some
valuable history there is a lot of
rich and vibrant history its problem is
the present so
uh we sent down thomas finnegan to give
us a brief history lesson on some
california facts
[Music]
good morning steven i'm here in sunny
california to give you some safety
lessons for skateboarding oh great
california is of course
where skateboarding started in the 1970s
yep with the dog town and z boys see
boys that's exactly correct he's got it
right
okay mr finnegan oh yeah be careful
there safety first
thank you for our viewers we appreciate
it
all right uh that helmet's not
sized to fit
it's bleeding
all right thank you thomas finnegan did
you have anything else you wanted to add
to the wine
bit about smelt and stuff because you
were telling me when you were getting
your beard put on you're like i know a
lot about california
i just kind of laid it out for you okay
just don't build in certain places and
there was one other thing that they said
la even in these drought years had like
three and a half inches of rain and they
said if people would just start
collecting their rain water instead of
the government
building things to dump it into the
ocean essentially right just running
down the street running down their
aquaduck whatever into the ocean
they would solve 30 to 40 percent of
their water problem just by
helping people get cisterns and rain
collection they did it in australia it
took about five years and they solved
their problem
yeah california has known about this for
decades by the way
in australia as well they've been if i'm
not mistaken more at the forefront of uh
is it desalination or desalinization
detail well that that is i don't know
which one it is desalinization there we
go it has the zen yeah so they've done
more and i know look here's the issue
when you look up as to why they don't do
it
um it is expensive but the costs have
come down yeah quite a bit a lot and
they certainly could come down more but
the biggest barrier to entry of course
is the environmental laws right
um again because and not said that there
isn't any kind of environmental
impact however at a certain point you
have to
weigh the pros and cons go well it could
be a negative feedback loop where then
the world gets warmer yeah but if you
have a netting supply of water because
the majority of our earth
is it that seems like it would be and
you know what one other thing too that i
want to say
this is also just an example of how how
pampered we've become when we're talking
about some of these problems and i'm not
saying that if the world doesn't get uh
you know warmer 1.6 degrees that
we're not all going to die because
obviously that's settled science what i
am saying however is
the fact that we consider this so
catastrophic um when right now for
example in michigan we've talked about
this
great lakes last year record highs this
year still really high yeah
okay record growth for their crops in
the midwest
i always use cherries just because it's
something that's really big if you guys
know
in michigan it's a very difficult crop
because what it requires
the cherry right it requires a very long
slow sowing slow thawing winter
yeah meaning it can't be extremes hot or
cold because they say global warming and
go well that's really cool let's see now
it's extreme it's
the extremes it's climate change well a
cherry if it for example
uh if if uh it thaws once and then
frosts again
you'll lose all your chips yeah yeah
yeah the same thing with grapes so very
is it the same thing
so it's a pretty good metric because
it's a long slow
thawing winter and then a moderate a
good summer that's what's required for
cherries
record sherry crops but i just use that
to try and put a finer point on it we've
had unbelievable crop yields
in the great lakes region we were told
of course great like great lakes the
most important fresh body of water in
the world we were told that it would be
gone
by 2021. i think in 2017 they said
record lows
record highs okay so now they are saying
though however
the record highs and the record crop
yields and the cherries
uh this is climate change now and so we
need to act okay let me
if you take us out of this century so
any other century
ever in the history of human existence
okay
and try to explain that concept to them
they'd be having harvest festivals right
they'd be going look
oh my gosh the lord has blessed us we
have more water than ever and we're
the the ground is more fertile than we
could possibly imagine we're planting
things we didn't even know could grow
here
look at the cherries we didn't look we
have we have an overabundance that we
could have never imagined in both
water sustenance and someone goes
actually that's a problem
they burn you at the stake they were
like i guess sacrificing carl
worked yeah that's great turns out all
we need for record uh high levels in the
lake is more
corals to burn anybody got a carl
so i'm just just trying to put it into
context now i'm not saying that there
aren't problems and we don't need to be
responsible with our environment you're
responsible yes
no i'm saying no i'm not saying that we
don't need to be responsible yeah okay
jack dorsey
you're gonna call me on everything don't
forget the suspended president what i am
saying though is we have to we have to
weigh the good and the bad
of course you have to balance your
policies out when you're talking about
the environment and people and in
california right now they've said the
only thing that matters really is
environment
and people really do come second because
if you're allowing your population to
live
homeless in san francisco you're just
perpetuating homelessness right
you're just normalizing it you're
supposed to try to help people get out
of that you're supposed to say hey
don't poop in the streets over here
because that's not sanitary we've gone
away from doing that
in one reason and here's a pervert and
i'll leave it with this we're going to
take our costume winner at uh mug club
oh you guys can comment below
um also what what this is since this is
the last week of cultural appropriation
month it's been a wonderful june let us
know which countries you want
next year yeah and we'll compile a list
here's what you also have in california
and it's very similar to michigan okay
i use these states as examples because
they're states that shouldn't suck but
they do
you have a few people on the coast in
california
well who do you think is more affected
by uh you know
not building dams and needing access to
what it's people inland
right it's people inland these are
people where they're living in regions
where probably they're getting less
water
this really affects them but because of
people on the coast who don't know what
it's like to live in an actual desert
climate
not near a large body of water those
people suffer
a perfect example in michigan there was
a vote i believe it was the u.p if i'm
not mistaken someone can call me on it i
don't remember the exact region it was
either the upper peninsula
or a northern county in michigan they
had a vote
which shouldn't have been a vote they
have a wolf problem
no now as far as i'm concerned um
if you see a wolf no vote
you deal you should deal with the wolf
now there was a significant enough
wolf problem where they wanted to allow
a wolf hunt now i know you guys may have
some opinions on
on whether you should be able to
endanger me okay fine whatever but the
point is
there was enough of a there were there
was enough of a prevalence of
wolves in this area of michigan where
they said we need to have
a concerted wolf hunt and they weren't
allowed to because of people who live
nowhere near the wolf
area of the state saying that well it
would be mean to take out
wolves and they said no no we have
wolves it's a problem with our livestock
it's a problem you know we're concerned
for our kids and they said yeah well you
should think about the environment
and that the wolves keep the coyotes in
check they said well okay
be that as it may right now we're a
little more concerned with keeping the
wolves
in check that's at the forefront of our
mind and because of some hipster to
coffee shop down state i believe it was
a statewide vote it could be mistaken
uh someone voting in flint or someone
voting in detroit
people don't get to keep their own
families or their own livestock safe
this is what happens you have these
elitists who have voted shitty policies
into their not and by the way not just
voted but voted in elected officials who
then bring with them like we're talking
about the deep state and the deep state
happens even on a local municipal level
unelected officials who serve to
maintain the status quo
of regulations for unelected officials
and guess what happens
it affects the rest of the state
like a cancer make it a good point
because we got to go out on this
california's doing the same thing you
cannot shoot a deer that is eating all
of your grapes or a turkey
that is destroying your grapevines you
can't do it because somebody took a vote
in la and san francisco and said i would
be mean to shoot the deer you can't
shoot them
you cannot even if they're eating all of
your grapes and you cannot shoot the dna
or the turkey look berkey or any of
those this is why i need to be governor
of michigan although i can't i wouldn't
be coming to california because i
wouldn't want to live there but
you know what okay new pop you can't
shoot him poison the grapes
problem solved all right we're going to
mug club gonna read your costume winner
leave a comment below wish me luck with
the surgery but you don't have to
youtube piss off
you